you know it dawned on me earlier this
week i've never done a video on the
original taken done videos on the
inferior sequels but
never the original and that my friends
is a wrong that needs to be writed today
so let's do that
taken that was my liam neeson
might not be the last time in this video
so what can i say about taking that
hasn't already been said
about taken taken's completely badass
when i saw the trailer i was like that
movie might be good
and i thought i was like it was just
better than i thought it was gonna be
it's a movie that keeps it in the pocket
the entire time when i think about a
movie
in which simple isn't an insult simple
is actually
a compliment it uses its simplicity to
its advantage taken is definitely up
there on the list because the premise is
completely simple it's about a dad
played by liam neeson and his daughter's
being kidnapped over in france and he's
like
all right here i come with one of the
greatest monologues
ever it's an important monologue
actually it's the most important
part of this entire movie i think that
scene where he's like
kim this is very important they're going
to take you dads don't usually act that
way when their daughters are about to be
kidnapped so right there you know this
guy
definitely he indeed does have a
particular set of skills
we're talking he doesn't door-to-door
sell vacuums he has
he has other skills but the reason this
scene is important is because he gives
this guy the opportunity
to just walk away it's profoundly
important for the setup and execution of
this entire movie
i mean the bad guys in this movie are
kidnappers and traffickers of women so
we the audience we didn't need
an excuse for them to be put into the
ground but now the movie makes it that
personal because
it shows us the phone call conversation
between liam neeson
and the one who kidnapped his daughter
not only do we see the guy be a dick
about it and
basically verbally smack the dad of the
person he just kidnapped
good luck but now we saw liam neeson
give this guy a warning he legit
warned him he didn't need to do that if
you let my daughter go now that'll be
the end of it
but if you don't i will look for you
i will find you and i will kill you
and the guy completely ignores the
warning so not only are we on liam
neeson's side but the bad guy ignored
the warning and
cinema law says he must be punished i
don't make it up and send him a lot
really the movie could have happened
with or without that phone call
but the fact that that phone call
happened i just feel like it shifts the
dynamic of this entire
the the vibe of the movie the phone call
is the thing in this movie
that makes the movie humor me for a
second try to imagine the plot of taking
playing out
exactly how it did without that phone
call it's just like you can't do it guys
half this video is talking about that
one phone call
it's awesome though it's one of the
reasons taken to me just it seems to
have more nuance it seems
smarter it seems like a passion project
of sorts and it being the liam neeson
show the movie just has amazing pacing
we have enough set up to get a grasp on
the family dynamic we have enough setup
to see liam neeson's love for his
daughter
or the very least paranoia this is
taken's the ultimate i told you so
movie this entire time this dad is so
paranoid that bad things are going to
happen to his daughter
and the moment he lets his guard down a
bad thing happens that's right there's a
lesson to be learned
for the dad liam neeson in this movie
and that lesson is never listen to other
people if you're paranoid you're not
paranoid enough you'd be more paranoid
but whereas the setup doesn't waste your
time
it's not too long and before long we
just we have liam neeson with this guy
in the cab and he's just
punching him and from there the movie
with excellent pacing just takes you
through the story well the story being
dad going to get his daughter back like
i said
simple but the simplicity is part of the
beauty of it where the movie really
makes me go okay you're doing that movie
thing
is when the bad guys have the
opportunity to kill liam neeson they're
like no no let's tie him up and
monologue to him
so we can give him the opportunity to
escape and then the movie ends and it
never feels too long it doesn't feel
too long-winded and it's set up the
movie never feels like it's dragging its
feet it's just
it's just long enough it's just long or
short enough to be perfect i'm not
saying the movie's flawless i'm saying
for what it's going for it is perfect
execution you know me i love movies like
this to have
the simple pure motivations this dad
following the path to the ones who
kidnapped his daughter
littering the path with bodies along the
way whether it be that or a guy looking
for the one who killed his dog
littering the path with bodies along the
way there's something about those simple
plots that i find
perfect in my enjoyment i'm actually
kind of convinced that john wick
happened
because taken happened taken was that
thing that was like okay revenge flicks
are there now it's a movie that was so
glorious the sequels never lived up to
it neither did
any movie in which liam neeson was now
the badass that happened after taken
there were a slew of those movies you
know liam neeson was like the go-to
badass guy
never enjoyed any of those posts taken
liam neeson as a badass movies as much
as i enjoyed taking i don't even know
what to rate it because
as i always enjoy it when i re-watch it
nothing beats that
time that first time i watched take and
i walked down the movie theater my
friend and i were like
that was that was too badass i suppose
is it worth buying on blu-ray kind of
movie but in the end in the words of the
great harrison ford
um i don't care because to me taken
absolutely is
awesome tacular
all right so taken have you seen it what
did you think about i feel like you
probably have by now but
hey you never know but regardless what's
your favorite revenge
tale whatever movie it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you